julien julien oui pardon excusez moi je
réfléchissais 1 mais tu réfléchis à quoi
à nous détacher tout ça et alors et
alors oui exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les pc cela existe depuis déjà plus d'un
an et demi
alors c'est vrai à l'échelle de
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est quoi
c'est un pet scolopendre mais jus de ma
fenêtre
ça fait quand même un peu plus genre je
sais pas un pet dragon d'un géant en
fait en vrai pour vous donner une petite
idée ça fait vingt mois donc à peu près
une centaine de vidéos une trentaine de
millions de vues et puis surtout quatre
cent mille abonnés
et comme la fin de l'année approche le
début de l'année suivante approche aussi
du coup c'est le meilleur moment pour un
faire un petit bilan est de prendre des
résolutions bon c'est vrai c'est ma
chaîne donc dans l'absolu je fais ce que
je veux mais on est quand même 400
milles donc j'ai pas envie de faire les
choses dans mon coin alors je vais
réfléchir à haute voix on va en parler
un peu tous ensemble ça va être un beau
bordel et à la fin je déciderai pour la
suite en gros la question que je me pose
y en a plusieurs sur la fréquence des
vidéos d'abord des centaines de vidéos
donc une par semaine sur des sujets des
fois léger et des fois plus sérieux dans
tous les cas ça représente plusieurs
heures de travail de recherche
d'écriture de tournage etc
oui alors je sais ce que vous vous dites
plein de vidéos ça veut dire plein de
vue donc ça veut dire
bah non pas du tout
non du coup dans un premier temps
première annonce je vais espace est un
petit peu les vidéos sur d'été c'est le
temps de me consacrer à un autre projet
car un lien avec dtc mais dont je peux
pas parler pour le moment la question
c'est ensuite début 2018 est ce que je
reviens à une vidéo par semaine une
vidéo tous les 15 jours ou pas vraiment
de rythme je me pose la question je vous
pose la question et puis à la question
des formats j'ai pas envie d'arrêter les
formats actuels ceux qui font l'identité
de dtc que ce soit les faces calmes les
tests les dans son corps le petit
dernier qu'on a testé récemment qui
s'appelle la question tout le monde se
pose
mais j'ai un peu envie de me renouveler
et tenter des trucs vraiment différent
des trucs un peu plus spontanée des
trucs un peu moins écrit sur le terrain
par exemple genre un peu comme les tests
mais en plus léger et puis aussi de la
fiction genre des sketches j'ai plein
d'idées il y en a pas mal qui ont un
lien avec la santé donc ça peut se
passer sur dtc ou pas je sais pas
vraiment si sa place missiles donc vous
voyez je me pose plein de questions et
je suis sûr que vous pouvez m'aider à y
répondre et je suis sûr que vous vous
posez aussi plein de questions alors ce
que je vous propose c'est qu'on se
retrouve tous ensemble pour réfléchir un
petit peu à tout ça est aussi juste pour
tailler le bout de gras autour d'un live
au moment où je tourne cette vidéo je
n'ai pas encore décidé de la date et de
l'heure de ce live je vous annoncerai ça
sur twitter et sur la page facebook de
dtc donc n'hésitez pas allez vous
abonner histoire d'être au courant le
moment en attendant de nous retrouver en
live et discuter en veux tu en voilà
vous connaissez la chanson mettez vous
bien et surtout portez vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]